first congrats on the movie um and i've
been a fan of yours for a very long time
if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done before what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
oh my god such a responsibility to
answer to this question
[Music]
actually i'm attached to
different films
maybe
i don't know malena my
the italian film elena i think was
a special movie and i think it's still
beautiful today
and um
but
you know uh it's difficult to talk about
ourselves i think it's the public who
has to decide uh what they prefer you
know i keep doing to work with different
directors from different countries and
uh
uh i had the possibility to experiment
and have different different experiences
and
um
then you know right now i'm in a play
uh maria kalas letters memoirs
we started the play in
in france then we went to italy now we
go to istanbul and london the place in
three different languages
and it's so dif
interesting is the first time for me and
um
when tom wolf asked me to play
this role i was
scared because it was my first time on
stage but i couldn't resist and
and it is so interesting to play this
duality
of maria callas
diva divina adonis immense talent at the
same time a woman with a simple heart
and this duality in a different way is
the same duality that i
uh i found in uh
the vanaselmo even though you know it's
a completely different
situation but the role was so
interesting uh
i had the feeling that with this role i
could play i could play
in a different way and i could break the
mold in which i have been cast
many times in my life
i gained some weight and the makeup
everything contributed to create
a new role for me and also i think that
aging helps to opening new possibilities
as well
and
so some way devana selman is described
as
natural sociopath
because
she's bright
she's charming at the same time cold and
manipulative
and i'm playing this duality is what
interests me
people love uh watching liam neeson uh
kick ass
why do you think it is that people love
watching uh liam neeson punch people in
the face
no i think that liam neeson even when
he's really aggressive
there is always a human side that come
come out you know talking about duality
that's why i think that you know uh
yes this part
in the character there is a violence but
also something that you want to protect
him for some reason you know so she's a
um
she's an assassin at the same time
there is this
incredible sensibility and um
because he's a great actor so
you know he can play all the different
aspects of the character i am a huge fan
of the wachowskis and if you don't mind
um can you reminisce a little bit about
what it was like working with them on
the matrix movies because i think
they're just such visionary filmmakers
yeah they they know what they want
they're so precise and
i remember was a really great experience
to be
with them
and um
and it was so incredible
because i remember first time
uh i saw matrix i was in paris and i
came out from the the movie and i said
oh my god i would love to work in a
movie like that
and then i
they called me for for a test so i went
to los angeles and i did a test with
them and then i was so happy when uh i
could have you know the possibility to
work with them and uh we were in
sydney we shot in sydney and uh
i still remember today that you know the
the atmosphere on set was great and um
you know still today
they make
incredible movies and good movies
yeah uh they're they're what we call
talented
talented yeah yeah you know
even this movie you know i wanted to
work with liam nizon and
because i respect him very much i want
to work with martin campbell because he
really knows how to create magic when he
steps behind the camera
and
still today after all those years
as something happened to me that was so
funny i once i was in the airport and
someone came to me and he told oh my god
you know
i love you you're a great actress i love
all your roles and you know the one i
prefer is
zorro
she thought i was getting to the jones
the key question is did you and i said
thank you for watching
sign for you that's great
on that note i need to wrap i'm just
gonna say again uh thank you for
everything and i wish you nothing but
the best
thank you so much have a good day
you